on a pu remarquer
improviser tous ses discours
on ressort de placement
on les pleure madame
c'est humain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
tous
il
salut parce que le scepticisme n'est
jamais aussi fort que lorsqu'il procède
à son autocritique
je voudrais éclairer un problème
potentiel en fait j'ai peur qu'une
croyance irrationnelle se soit glissée j
les plus fervents défenseurs du
scepticisme
mais avant de se pencher dessus je
voudrais commencer par une distinction
qui me semble d'une importance capitale
je vois deux types de croyance de
grandes familles d'un côté le mot
croyances renvoie à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler des croyances de surface c'est à
dire ce qu'on croit consciemment par
exemple si on me demande si je peux
faire une introspection et répondre je
crois où je ne crois pas de l'autre côté
le mot croyance peut renvoyer à des
croyances qu'on pourrait dire profonde
ça désigne les croyances qui ont un
ancrage inconscient il arrive qu'elles
correspondent à une croyance de surface
par exemple je crois consciemment que je
m'appelle paul mais je le crois aussi
inconsciemment si j'entends mon prénom
dans la rue je vais me retourner comme
par réflexe
elles sont présentes en nous et elles
influencent notre pensée nos choix et
nos actions mais parfois les croyances
profondes restent en profondeur elles ne
parviennent pas à la conscience on ne
sait pas qu'on croie quelque chose même
si je n'ai jamais pensé consciemment la
mécanique quantique sont impressionnants
il se peut que rencontrant une
chercheuse en mécanique quantique je
sois impressionné c'est déjà intéressant
parce que cela fait des croyances de
surface des méta croyances je veux dire
un truc tout simple croire consciemment
x c'est croire que l'on croit en x et
c'est donc aussi vrai à l'envers ne pas
avoir de croyance consciente en y
cela revient à croire qu'on ne croit pas
en y vous comprenez le problème auquel
on fait face il arrive qu'une couvert de
surface soins contredite par une
croyance profonde
on croit qu'on croit avant x alors que
en réalité on n'y croit pas vraiment
peut-être que si on me demande tu ai
trouvés impressionnants toile et
spécialiste de mécanique quantique
je fais une introspection et pense
pas vraiment la physique tu sais ça fait
ni chaud ni froid et puis je rencontre
cette physicienne
elle me raconte sur quoi elle bosse et
bim je suis impressionné j'imagine que
si on se donne pour but de tester nos
croyances
il faut impérativement prendre cela en
compte si je ne m'occupe que des
créances consciente donc celle que je
verbalise je risque de passer à côté de
croyances qui joue un rôle central dans
ma vie parce que les croyances profondes
sont celles qui nous engage c'est-à-dire
qu'elles définissent notre personnalité
nos préférences nos valeurs etc il est
tentant de dire que les présences
profonde prime sur les présences de
surface si je dis croit en x mais que
mon comportement semble indiquer le
contraire on sera tenté de conclure que
ma vraie croyance ce n'est pas de croire
en x pour prendre cet exemple on dira tu
croyais que la physique quantique ne
pouvait pas apprécié au nez mais en fait
la vérité c'est que c'est impressionnant
sous-entendu tu avais tort de croire que
ça ne t'a impressionner pas et donc tu
avais tort de croire que tu croyais que
ça ne m'impressionne pas
j'ai cru en mon introspection mais je me
suis trompé l'expérience m'a révélé que
j'aurais dû croire que ça
m'impressionnait
autrement dit le comportement révèle nos
vrais croyances et les croyances qu'on
identifie dans notre tête quand on y
pense consciemment ne valent peut-être
pas grand-chose tant qu'elles n'ont pas
été mises à l'épreuve
d'où l'importance d'observer notre
comportement de réflexes nos attitudes
et je me dis que le scepticisme est donc
d'autant plus pertinente qu'il
s'intéresse aux croyances profondes à
ses croyances qui engage effectivement
nos comportements après tout le problème
des anti vaccins c'est bien que ça
véhicule un discours qui va avoir des
effets super concret dans le monde des
gens vont refuser de se faire vacciner
si tous les anti pacs du monde disait
schématiquement on n'y croit pas et on
ira star ac' signer quand même on invite
tout le monde à faire pareil on ne
dépenserait pas d'énergie à découvrir
nos arguments c'est donc ces croyants de
cela qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui et j'ai
bien l'impression qu'une croyance
profonde particulièrement peu solide est
extrêmement répandu et ce même chez les
défenseurs du scepticisme le libre
arbitre
pourquoi ne parle t'on jamais de la
croyance dans le libre arbitre
pourquoi n'est ce pas l'objet de toutes
les attentions vous pourrez être tentés
de dire que c'est une des croyances
irrationnelles les plus pauvres du monde
ça mériterait de faire la une grande et
bonne king la société dans sa totalité
fonctionne sur une prémisse complètement
fausse plus embêtant
pourquoi continue-t-on de se comporter
comme si on était libre bon peut-être
que je vais un peu vite
alors arrêtons nous deux minutes sur
cette histoire de libre arbitre ici je
parle de libre arbitre dans son
acception usuelles c'est à dire l'idée
selon laquelle il est possible pour un
sujet conscient de prendre une décision
librement en ce sens l'espace où a lieu
la prise de décision libre ce serait la
conscience il existe au moins trois
manières pour défendre l'idée que le
libre arbitre est une illusion
la première épreuve celle approche
psychanalytique
cela consiste à mettre en avant
l'existence de désir de valeur d'idées
de mécanismes inconscients qui dans les
coulisses de notre esprit tient les
ficelles et oriente nos choix nos coûts
nos préférences nos décisions l'argument
pourrait être formulée ainsi puisque
nous savons être influencé par notre
inconscient mais comme sommes incapables
de savoir à quel point est que nous
sommes par conséquent incapable
d'identifier avec suffisamment de
certitude les zones de notre activité
mentale ou l'inconscience j'aurais aucun
rôle où la conscience serait libre de
toute influence inconsciente
nous sommes jamais en mesure d'affirmer
que telle ou telle décision fut prise en
toute lucidité
c'est à dire pour les raisons que l'on
croit suivant le trajet de réflexion
consciente
on a suivi bon c'est vrai que les
sceptiques sont pas souvent hyper
convaincu par la psychanalyse
la seconde approche et sociologique elle
consiste à repérer des tendances dans
les prises de décision au sein de
milieux socioculturels forcément au bout
d'un moment si on pense comme les gens
de son milieu si on s'habille comme les
gens de son milieu si on vote comme les
gens de son milieu si on écoute la même
musique que les gens de son milieu
bah on peut commencer à se demander si
on est vraiment livre là encore il
s'agit de dire comme précédemment
puisque
observons une influence de notre milieu
social sur nos croyances et notre
comportement
et comme il est impossible de délimiter
avec une extrême précision son champ
d'action on ne peut être certain que
telle ou telle décision n'est pas en
réalité une réaction cause et in fine et
par un milieu socioculturel données si
on combine une influence de
l'inconscient l influence du milieu
social ça fait beaucoup mais c'est vrai
que les sceptiques sont encore assez
réticent à l'idée d'intégrer la
sociologie dans leur processus de
réflexion à cet égard d'ailleurs je
renvoie à cet article il ya cette vidéo
alors il reste le troisième argument
celui qui est sur le papier imparable
parce qu'il vient des sciences dures
depuis benjamin libe et ce fut ensuite
approfondi par ses héritiers
on a découvert que le cerveau décide
avant la confiance ou pour aller plus
vite
le cerveau des six depuis une fraction
de seconde plus tard nous vivons
l'expérience consciente de la prise de
décision
parce qu'évidemment c'est
que l'on appelle le libre arbitre
l'impression qu'il ya quelque chose tel
qu'un soi c'est la personne qui parle
quand on dit jeu et que cette personne
peut décider librement de faire ceci ou
cela
voilà un consensus scientifique existe
sur cette question il n'y a aucune
preuve de l'existence de ce jeu libre de
décider
rien ne dit que c'est par mon activité
conscient donc pas non plus par mes
réflexions et mon raisonnement super
méga rationnel que je décide ça rend
modestes à noter que même parmi les gens
plutôt réticent aux approche
psychanalytique et sociologiques comme
les quatre apôtres du rationalisme a t
on a commencé à reconnaître l'étendue de
la catastrophe
sam harris a consacré un livre pour
expliquer que le libre arbitre est une
illusion et daniel dennett le moins
suspect des quatre a aussi intégré ses
recherches à son travail et il défend
désormais une conception du libre
arbitre qui n'a plus grand chose à voir
avec le sens qu'on associe à
l'expression habituellement bref si vous
voulez en savoir davantage sur cette
question fascinante
je vous invite à vous renseigner et j'ai
mis plein de liens en descriptions
toujours est il que je vais revenir à
mon problème initial puisque on a
compris grâce à la science que le libre
arbitre était une illusion
pourquoi continuer d'agir d'une façon
qui nie cette conclusion on pourrait par
exemple éviter de se moquer des
individus en pointant du doigt la bêtise
de leur poste ou de leurs commentaires
parce que se moquer ou stigmatiser une
personne pour avoir dit un truc qu'on
juge bête ça n'a de sens que si on
considère que cette personne est libre
pour le dire autrement se moquer d'une
personne parce qu'elle subit une
situation dans laquelle elle n'a eu
aucun choix c'est de la pure cruauté
à moins d'être cruel on ne se moquerait
pas d'un sourd parce qu'il n'a pas
entendu ce qu'on lui a dit on ne se
moquerait pas de quelqu'un qui renverse
sa tasse de café parce qu'on l'a
violemment bousculée on ne se moquerait
pas d'un sportif qui doit abandonner une
épreuve à cause d'une blessure
généralement on se moque on pointe du
doigt quelqu'un parce qu'on considère
que cette personne aurait pu se
comporter autrement la question de la
supposée bêtise ou intelligence d'un
individu forme donc un cas particulier
il est beaucoup plus facile de
reconnaître l'existence de contraintes
matérielles et physique que de
reconnaître l'existence de contrats de
mental en fait on se moque de la bêtise
de quelqu'un parce que l'on considère
qu'une personne peut réfléchir librement
parce qu'on entretient l'idée selon
laquelle chez l'être humain la réflexion
la capacité à réfléchir et penser
pourrait fonctionner à ce traitement
comme dans un monde à part un bon lit
de toute contrainte ou détermination
matériel l'esprit serait l'espace où se
manifeste la liberté des êtres humains
petite pause interactive il existe un
argument pour justifier qu'il faille
quand même traité des individus comme
s'il était libre je vais en parler plus
loin dans la vidéo vous l'avez sinon
prenez deux secondes pour y penser
reprenons du point de vue de ce que la
science nous apprend sur le libre
arbitre
il est tout aussi bête d'admirer pauline
pour son intelligence que de mépriser
jacques pour sa supposée bêtises on me
répondra peut-être que se moquer d'une
personne sur twitter les révélateurs de
rien que c'est simplement de l'humour
mais je ne crois pas je pense que c'est
révélateur de la manière dont on perçoit
les choses punta naiman si on voit
effectivement le comportement des gens
comme les effets d'un ensemble de causes
donc si notre croyance profonde c'est
que la qualité des raisonnements d'une
personne s'explique par des causes
externes alors la supposée bêtise d'une
personne cesse effectivement d'être
drôle et donc au lieu de blâmer
l'individu pour ses raisonnements où ses
prises de position on se met à
s'intéresser aux causes au facteur
déterminant on arrête de croire que
l'esprit est le seul responsable des
pensées qu'il produit si les décisions
d'un individu sont déterminées par un
cerveau on doit prendre sérieusement en
considération les conditions matérielles
dans lesquelles évoluent ce cerveau
mettons que monsieur x pour aller au
boulot prend sa voiture confortable et
silencieuse qui plus est ils passent par
une jolie drew de boisés le soleil
éclaire en son début de journée arrivé
au travail mais ça varié lui dise
bonjour avec respect et déférence voir
un peu de crainte puisqu'il est le
patron il s'installe dans un beau bureau
avec une porte il est dérangé que lorsqu
il autorise il a même une baie vitrée
madame y quant à elle marche un quart
d'heure entre des immeubles tout gris
avant de prendre un bus qui la mène à la
gare de rer où elle prendra le train
pendant 45 minutes debout c'est bruyant
ce ne sont pas forcément très bon enfin
quand elle arrive au travail déjà un peu
fatigué par ce trajet elle s'installe
dans son open space pas tellement moins
bruyant que le rer
elle dit bonjour en souriant à monsieur
x et essaie de se concentrer malgré le
bruit que fait son collègue
eh bien ces deux cerveaux ne sont pas du
tout soumis aux mêmes stimuli pas les
mêmes niveaux de stress pas les mêmes
niveaux de fatigue pas les mêmes
interactions sociales pas les mêmes
joies pas les mêmes difficultés
il ne faudrait pas s'étonner ensuite que
ces deux cerveaux ne produisent pas la
même vision du monde pas la même
raisonnement puisqu'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes valeurs pas les mêmes pensées qui
ne désirent pas les mêmes choses et
c'est l'avis de monsieur x le conduit
peut-être à vouloir maximiser ses
profits
la bid et madame y l'a conduit peut-être
à vouloir se reposer
il serait carrément injuste par exemple
de laisser entendre à madame y
qu'elle est seule responsable du regard
qu'elle porte sur le monde de sa fatigue
de son manque de motivation de ce désir
ou valeur se contenter de dire les
individus sont biaisés donc tout réduire
à une dimension psychologique individuel
c'est manquer le plus important dans la
vidéo précédente j'ai un peu abordé ce
sujet là depuis un angle psychologique
justement histoire d'être ironique cette
fois je voudrais poser la question
depuis un angle davantage philosophique
en demandant quelle est l'idéologie qui
se cache derrière la croyance dans le
libre arbitre
pourquoi laisse-t-on autant de côté les
déterminismes pourquoi continue-t-on à
faire comme si on était libre on
pourrait malgré le consensus
scientifique défend l'idée selon
laquelle ce n'est pas irrationnel de
croire dans le libre arbitre
on pourrait dire du point de vue de
l'individu
il est logique de croire qu'on est libre
un peu comme il est rationnel du point
de vue des enfants de croire au père
noël
c'est ce qu'explique cette super vidéo
précisément il y est rappelé que la
rationalité et d'affaires de point de
vue et que mis à part en logique
formelle on n'évalue pas un raisonnement
sans prendre en compte le contexte dans
lequel il s'inscrit
mais alors ici que les le contexte quel
est le contexte qui justifie qu'on
continue de croire au libre arbitre et
bien c'est la société le monde social
mais en quoi ce contexte suffit-il à
justifier une croyance erronée
est ce le fait que tout le monde agit
comme si on était libres que tout le
monde a effectivement l'impression
d'être libre bah pas sûr si 80 % des
gens étaient anti pacs devrait quand
même déconstruire cette croyance c'est
pas une histoire de majorité c'est qu'on
a un sentiment à ce moment une intuition
pragmatique il vaut mieux croire au
vaccin
ou pour le dire autrement on a intérêt à
ce que les gens ne doute pas des vaccins
une question massive se cache derrière
ce sentiment que faut-il penser que
faut-il croire que vaut-il mieux croire
vous souvenez de notre petite pause
interactive il ya cinq minutes j'ai dit
qu'il y avait un argument qui pouvait
justifier qu'on continue de traiter des
individus comme s'il était libre et bien
par exemple ça peut être pour inciter
quelqu'un à changer de comportement
typiquement sur twitter des experts
corrige des vulgarisateurs
mais du coup vous voyez le problème la
justification derrière la
responsabilisation individuelle derrière
la croyance dans le libre arbitre
c'est au fond une justification
essentiellement pragmatique donc
politique c'est l'idée que c'est mieux
pour la société de continuer à faire
comme si on était libres ce qui révèle
une espèce de paradoxes pour pouvoir se
revendiquer libre il faut en fait se
positionner politiquement il faut
pouvoir justifier que c'est bon pour
l'organisation de la société
bon je résume le raisonnement qui me
conduit à cette conclusion
1 on s'intéresse aux croyances parce
qu'elle implique des comportements 2 si
le critère ultime est celui de la
validité scientifique
alors il faut abandonner la croyance
dans le libre arbitre et s'entraîner à
agir en ce sens par exemple en
abandonnant l'idée de la responsabilité
individuelle
3 si l'on veut continuer à croire au
libre arbitre à agir comme si on était
libres alors il faut faire appel à un
autre critère pour justifier ce choix je
ne vois pas d'autres critères que celui
du pragmatisme
on a intérêt à faire comme si on était
libre
4 si on limite cette justification à
l'échelle individuelle
cela revient à dire je peux croire
quelque chose de faux si ça me fait
plaisir
et dans ce cas on arrête de vouloir
corriger et croyances fausses des gens à
cela on peut avoir envie de préciser on
peut croire des choses fausses si ça
nous fait plaisir et si ça n'implique
pas de comportement problématique pour
la société et c'est vrai que c'est un
argument mis en avant par la sphère
sceptiques ont des bonnes les croyances
fausses qui ont un impact sur la société
5 donc tout ceci impose de prendre en
compte l'échelle collective
il nous est permis de croire quelque
chose de faux car cela participe au bon
fonctionnement de la société
ou parce que cela n'entrave pas le bon
fonctionnement de la société et donc
cela impôts de se poser une question
très difficile
qu'est ce qu'une société qui fonctionne
bien en somme ça impose de poser
explicitement la question politique
continuer de se comporter comme si on
était libres alors que le consensus
scientifique révèle que cette liberté
est illusoire
cela revient à déclarer
il ya plus important que la vérité il y
à la politique c'est à dire que la
distinction vrai faux n'est pas le
critère ultime pour décider quelle
croyance qu ont droit de cité si le
consensus scientifique n'est pas le
critère ultime permettant de distinguer
les bonnes et mauvaises croyance à
quelle méthode pouvons-nous nous
raccrocher eh bien je crois qu'il faut
faire de la philosophie mais c'est hyper
compliqué philo parce qu'il s'agit de
questionner des valeurs de s'interroger
sur ce qui est bon ou mauvais et cela
impose de produire des réflexions qui ne
sont pas réductibles à des jugements
empiriquement vérifiable alors pourquoi
cet oubli
il ya paradoxalement je crois qu'on peut
en trouver l'explication dans l'histoire
de la philosophie elle même alors soyons
schématique de seconde
les anciens c'est à dire ici aristote
disait en gros une société juste et une
société on accorde aux gens ce qu'ils
méritent
bon d'accord mais comment sait-on qui
mérite quoi
aristote étonnant de ce qu'on appelle
les tics de la vertu pour faire vite une
éthique conséquentialiste se concentre
sur les conséquences de l'action une
bonne action est une action qui a de
bonnes conséquences une éthiques
déontologiques insiste sur des règles la
bonne action et celle qui suit un devoir
moral l'éthique de la vertu se concentre
sur les traits de personnalité on
considère qu'il ya des dispositions
vertueuse est ce cela qu'on valorise on
se demande telle personne est elle
vertueuse et ça revient à se demander
monsieur x at il une bonne personnalité
bon mais c'est quoi une bonne
personnalité
comment on définit ça on n'a pas
beaucoup avancé là et bien en fait en
fonction d'une chose hyper importante le
telos c'est à dire la finalité
l'objectif qu'on se donne
en somme une société se fixe un objectif
et ce qui va dans le sens de l'objectif
et considérés comme vertueux et ce qui
fait obstacle à l'objectif est considéré
comme du vi seront récompensés celles et
ceux dont la personnalité est considéré
comme vertueuse c'est-à-dire compatible
avec les objectifs que s'est donnée la
société mettons qu'une société se donne
comme objectif d'être la meilleure en
sport eh bien elle va encourager et
récompenser les dispositions corporelle
et mentale qui favorisent la performance
sportive
évidemment on peut imaginer plein de
déclinaisons une société pourrait se
donner comme objectif d'être super
solidaires ou super écologique ou super
pieuse et à chaque fois cela implique et
définit des vertus et des vices
spécifiques vous voyez que ceux-ci qui
décident de l'objectif que se donne la
société c'est super important puisque ça
revient à demander qui décide que tel
trait de caractère est vertueux ou
vicieux c'est chaud dans notre société
sportive imaginaire qui valorise le
tempérament compétitif un musicien
chétive qui préfèrent légalité et
l'entraînent vivre est sans doute dans
la misère et ça ne choquerait personne
puisque cette personnalité serait
synonyme de vis ça paraît pas hyper cool
et ce problème se pose dans le vraiment
que nous connaissons comme dans le
sultanat de bruneï où on est prêt à
lapider les homosexuels parce qu'on
n'identifie l'homosexualité comme indice
faut pas s'étonner que ça refroidisse un
peu alors les modernes ont dit ouais
mais non en fait ça c'était juste c'est
pas ça une société juste
cette société où chacun à cliquer de
vivre selon sa propre conception de la
vie bonne dans la mesure bien entendu où
cette conception n'entre pas en conflit
avec celle d'autrui comme si chaque
individu allez pouvoir développer sa
propre éthique de la vertu dans son coin
et du coup tout le monde paie et hu est
morte à l on fait ça chaque impression
de trucs sur faire chez les autres c'est
la liberté ou et voilà comment est né le
fantasme de l'état neutre qui est juste
là pour éviter que ce soit le bordel et
qui laisse les gens faire ce qu'ils
veulent dans une certaine mesure
pourquoi je dis fantasmes parce que même
si beaucoup de gens croient aujourd'hui
vivre dans une telle société à savoir
une société qui ne ferait pas dans la
promotion d'une vie bonne en particulier
qui ne désignerait pas de vertu et de
vie
mais qui laisse rien des gens libres de
choisir ce qu'ils valorisent et bien ce
n'est pas le cas on est encore bien
travaillé par des questions de vie ces
deux vertus
on pourrait d'ailleurs y voir un petit
paradoxe parce que oui considéré qu'une
bonne société et une société où chacun
poursuit sa conception de la vie bonne
cela reste une conception de ce que
c'est qu'une société bonne au-delà de ça
notre société valorise et dévalorisent
explicitement plein de trucs elle fait
la promotion de certains traits de
caractère elle récompense des choix de
vie plutôt que d'autres ne pas se rendre
compte de ça c'est très embêtant quand
macron dit les jeunes français devrait
vouloir devenir milliardaire au delà de
la bêtise de la déclaration
c'est clairement une injonction qui
appartient à l'éthique de la vertu
macron ne dit pas il faut que les jeunes
inventent leur conception de la vie
bonne
il dit que les jeunes participent à
l'objectif capitaliste star temptation
c'est ça la vie bonne c'est la vie
entreprenariale les gens biens sont les
gens qui font du business et qui
réussissent ça ne veut pas simplement
dire qu'ils seront récompensés par de
l'argent ils sont aussi récompensés par
un statut social
c'est une valeur symbolique l'idée même
d'ascenseur social révèle que l'éthique
de la vertu est encore présente pas ce
que ça dit il vaut mieux être une
personne qui cherche à réussir que
d'être quelqu'un qui se content de ce
qu'il a à la vertu du travail
c'est quelque chose ça je ne résiste pas
à l'envié de partager avec vous cet
extrait de l'éloge de l'oisiveté de
bertrand russell que la ville finaux m'a
envoyé ce que je veux dire c'est que le
fait de croire que le travail est une
vertu et la cause de grands mots dans le
monde moderne et que la voie du bonheur
de la prospérité passe par une
diminution méthodique du travail la
morale du travail est une morale
d'esclaves et le monde moderne n'a mieux
besoin de l' esclavage
la notion de devoir du point de vue
historique sentant furent moyens qui ont
employé les puissants pour amener les
autres à consacrer leur vie aux intérêts
de leurs maîtres
plutôt kohler bien entendu ceux qui
détiennent le pouvoir se masquer cette
réalité à eux-mêmes en se persuadant que
leurs intérêts coïncident avec ceux de
l'humanité tout entière
cette illusion entretient une logique
individualiste et l'idée inconsciente
que la condition sine qua none pour être
une bonne personne
c'est chercher à être une bonne personne
c'est de vouloir progresser vouloir
réaliser ses rêves
et c'est comme si c'était chacun son
rêve comme si la société n'influençait
pas nos rêves
si vous êtes un footballeur de génie
vous croulerez sous l'argent et la
gloire
si vous êtes la meilleure triathlète du
monde personne ne vous connaîtra il vous
faudra probablement avoir un job à côté
si vous êtes une grande comédienne le
monde s'offre à vous si vous êtes un des
plus grands poètes français de la fin du
xxème siècle vous mourrez dans
l'indifférence générale
où est la fameuse neutralité ces
différences révèle un système de valeur
plus ou moins conscient
la société valorise davantage l'agilité
balle au pied que la course à pied et
les talents d'actrice que le don du
terrain
c'est une manière d'encourager certains
rêvent plutôt que d'autres on trouve des
valeurs des vertus et des vis dans
toutes les dimensions de la société même
là on dit qu'il n'y en a pas par exemple
les médecins de l'om est-ce qu'on
intègre et l'homosexualité dans la liste
des pathologies jusqu'en 1990 on peut
défendre l'idée selon laquelle ceux qui
déclaraient pathologique est un avatar
du péché autrefois dénoncé par l'église
il est dangereux de sous-estimer le rôle
que joue ce système de valeurs dans
l'organisation de la société croire la
société neutre
cela revient à croire que la société est
libre de toute idéologie qu'elle ne
favorise pas un système de valeurs
particulier mais personne ne nie
complètement l'existence de valeurs dans
la société
on voit bien dans le débat public et
surtout depuis quelques temps qu'on a
même tendance à insister sur
l'importance des valeurs alors ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on les présente comme des
évidences comme si elle tombait sous le
sens
quand on pense que des valeurs sont
évidentes quand on pense qu'elle devrait
être universellement partagée et bien un
certain sens on cesse de les voir comme
des valeurs on se dit que ces valeurs là
c'est la norme au fond et si elles sont
normales alors ça qu'elles
n'appartiennent pas à une idéologie
particulière c'est qu'elles n'ont pas de
couleur politique précise mais comment
la société pourrait-elle tenir cette
neutralité axiologique c'est-à-dire
s'organiser autour de valeurs
supposément universel et tenir à l'écart
tout valeur particulière toute idéologie
alors même qu'elle est bâti mu est
régulier par des humains c'est-à-dire
par des êtres désirant aux intérêts
en plus on l'a vu avec l'exemple des
médecins de l'om est ce une chance comme
la médecine n'a pas explicitement une
vocation moral et pourtant elle
participe à la définition d'une morale
en désignant ce qui est pathologique ou
en construisant un concept de folie qui
légitime de mettre à l'écart de la
société
certains individus alors comment peut-on
croire à cet idéal de société neutre et
bien précisément parce qu'on entretient
une conception de l'être humain comme un
individu libre et autonome parce qu'on
imagine que l'individu peut par lui même
atteindre la connaissance distinguer le
vrai du faux
se libérer de ses désirs et préférences
de sa culture et ses valeurs ont fini
par croire qu'il est capable de fonder
une société sur des principes neutre
mais évidemment comme on disait au tout
début
cette conception de l'être humain est
très naïve et elles impliquent une
conception tout aussi naïve du rapport à
la connaissance ici connaître
reviendrait au fond à découvrir
l'individu accéderait à ce qui
existeraient déjà en lui une sorte de
raison pure lui permettant ensuite
d'accéder à ce qui existe sans lui la
réalité il y aurait au fond une seule
bonne manière de réfléchir de traiter
les informations et elle serait
universellement partagée par toutes les
personnes qui pensent correctement on
fait alors une distinction tacite entre
le bon point de vue qui permet d'accéder
à la réalité et les mauvais points de
vue biaisée est défaillant c'est une
position rassurante parce qu'elle est
clair et manichéenne
l'objectif est simple il s'agit de
découvrir la réalité vraie qui fait
autorité
on en parlait ici et là de ce rapport à
la connaissance
une autre manière de concevoir le
rapport à la connaissance serait de
considérer celle-ci davantage comme une
production travailler à connaître
quelque chose rendrait moins à un
processus de révélations ou de
découverte que pourrait mener l'individu
dans son coin qu'à une construction
collective la production d'une culture
une représentation du monde
par exemple on verra l'école comme une
institution qui produit des esprits
c'est à dire qui les informe dans les
deux sens du terme leur transmet des
informations et leur donne une forme car
ces deux choses n'en sont qu'une définir
un programme scolaire donc définir le
contenu qu'on juge important d'apprendre
c'est choisir ce qui va construire le
regard des élèves sur le monde
cette approche reconnaît que les
conditions dans lesquelles nous vivons
détermine la manière dans notre esprit
fonctionne et donc définissent la forme
de notre conscience
la représentation que l'on se fait du
monde c'est ce qu'on disait avec madame
y
et monsieur x de ce point de vue on juge
improbable la croyance selon laquelle
l'être humain serait capable de
s'extirper ces conditions de vie pour
penser librement et produire un regard
neutre
telle une pure correspondance avec le
réel ainsi on considère que toute
connaissance est une production
collective étroitement lié à la manière
dont ce collectif fonctionne qui
composent cet ensemble individus comment
sont organisés les relations à
l'intérieur du collectif qu'à
l'hiérarchie mis en place quels rapports
de force et c est parce que cette
organisation apparaît comme contingentes
on reconnaît l'existence d'une multitude
de manières de réfléchir ce qui ne
revient pas à dire que toutes les
pensées se valent cela veut simplement
dire que leur valeur dépend du contexte
dans lequel ces pensées s'inscrit ici ce
qu'on appelle réalité une chose beaucoup
moins assuré beaucoup moins simple et
donc beaucoup moins autoritaire en
quelque sorte on insiste au contraire
sur son caractère multiple et fragmentée
et on voit comme un péril pour la pensée
l'idéalisation du rapport au monde sous
le mode binaire du réel irréel vrai faux
au lieu de fantasmer une pensée
universelle qui devrait s'imposer à tous
au lieu d'évaluer la pensée à l'aune de
sa relation aux vrais à la vérité comme
instance transcendante autorité suprême
on évalue la pensée à l'aune de sa
relation à la situation qui l'a vu
naître
ce peut être une situation d'énonciation
on s'attache alors à considérer un
argument ou une idée en fonction de la
thèse ou du débat auquel elle participe
ce peut être une situation sociale on
rappelle alors que la place qu'on occupe
dans la société conditionne le type
d'expérience auxquels on peut être
confrontés et que celles ci permettent
l'émergence d'un point de vue au delà de
la question de la connaissance croire
l'être humain libre et autonome cela
conduit également à défendre l'idée
selon laquelle un individu n'est
responsable que de ce qu'il fait lui
c'est à dire que l'on assimile la
responsabilité à la causalité
c'est croire que je ne suis responsable
que de ceux dont je suis la cause du
coup si on a l'impression de ne pas
participer activement aux injustices
sociales
si on pense ne pas en produire soi-même
donc si on considère ne pas être une
cause directe d'injustice on s'autorise
à conclure qu'on n'en est pas
responsable
on peut ainsi s'en désintéresser même si
on est d'accord pour dire que la vie est
dure
on invite les gens à s'en sortir par
eux-mêmes c'est entre autres la fonction
du développement personnel ou la
dernière arnaque mandate l'idéal de
résilience
mais on peut défendre l'idée contraire à
savoir que même si on n'est pas cause
directe d'injustice qui se déroule dans
la société on n'en est quand même
responsable
pour comprendre ce sens du concept de
responsabilité il suffit de penser à une
classe de maternelle
l'instituteur ou l'institutrice ne sont
pas cause du comportement des enfants
mais qu'ils en sont responsables
on peut aussi prendre comme exemple la
non-assistance à personne en danger
le fait de reconnaître qu'une personne
est en danger nous placent immédiatement
en situation de responsabilité en ce
sens on peut comprendre que les citoyens
aient une forme de responsabilité
vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe dans leur
société qu'ils en soient la cause ou non
dans une société comme la nôtre qui n'a
pas éradiqué la culture du violent les
femmes sont constamment en situation de
danger
c'est donc notre responsabilité à tous
d'y remédier
on pourrait pour finir proposer une
analogie la neutralité est à la
politique ce que l'idéal de rationalité
pur débarrassé de tout billet était la
psychologie un fantasme de toute
puissance
on veut croire que la société est neutre
comme on veut croire d'être victime
d'aucun biais
de la même manière qu'on gagne beaucoup
à reconnaître l'existence des pieds dans
l'exercice de notre jugement
on gagnerait beaucoup à reconnaître que
la société elle même est biaisé le
sexisme systémique où le patriarcat par
exemple après en ce sens comme un biais
social en psychologie un biais oriente
la manière dont on traite les données le
patriarcat oriente la manière dont on
traite des individus et dans un cas cela
peut produire des erreurs de résultats
ou de raisonnement dans le cas du
patriarcat cela produit des injustices à
répétition et comme pour les billets en
psychologie il y à une cécité au biais
de la société
si mes erreurs de raisonnement n'ont pas
d'effet sur ma vie je ne vais jamais me
rends compte que je raisonne mal et si
les erreurs dans le fonctionnement de la
société n'ont pas d'effets néfastes sur
ma vie je ne vais pas me rendre compte
que la société produit des injustices
c'est en cela que l'impression de
neutralité est dangereuse elle s'auto
confirme plus je me tient éloigné des
problèmes - je les voie moi je me sens
concerné - je me sens concerné plus je
pense être impartial et plus je pense
que mon regard est juste la neutralité
est une illusion produite par le statu
quo et en ce sens défendre la neutralité
c'est défendre le statu quo
c'est ce que rappelait paul nizan dans
les chais en garde à propos des
philosophes et qu'on peut reprendre et
si ceux qui ne souffrent pas du monde se
contente de le décrire en laissant
entendre qu'il est tel qu'il devrait
être celles et ceux qui souffrent de
l'état du monde s'attachent à décrire ce
qu'il faut transformer c'est le moment
de rappeler ce qu'on disait dans la
vidéo sur la sociologie il faut
distinguer la souffrance issus de la
condition humaine de la souffrance
issu de l'organisation sociale
cela fait écho à une question que j'ai
déjà posé dans plusieurs vidéos et qui
est à mon avis décisive pour savoir
comment nous réfléchissons il est
impératif de se demander le monde dans
lequel je vis me convient
pour plein de gens le monde est
objectivement dangereux pour eux la
société est un terrain miné leur vie
comporte des risques et des souffrances
supplémentaires que d'autres ne
connaissent pas l'injustice suprême
consiste à ne pas reconnaître cette
réalité là et l'idéologie dominante
notamment via la notion de méritocratie
s'attache précisément à masquer cette
réalité
le point de départ de cette vidéo c'est
de dire qu'on a de bonnes raisons de
croire qu'on n'est pas libre et on
remarque pourtant on continue d'agir
comme si on était libre pourquoi est-ce
seulement par habitude
si oui faut-il arrêter sinon si c'est
volontaire
c'est dans quel but quelle organisation
sociale dix pompes par là est ce une
affaire de responsabilisation
individuelle
j'aimerais que les amoureux du
scepticisme se pose ces questions si
nous déclarons qu'il vaut mieux agir
comme si nous étions libres alors nous
devons reconnaître que nous entretenons
un système de valeurs et ce n'est pas
grave ce qui est grave c'est de
l'ignorer le faire comme si ce n'était
pas le cas
certains biais cognitifs se nourrissent
de l'objectif que l'on se donne par
exemple le désir de prouver qu'on a
raison de croire ce qu'on croit
percevoir ce désir permet de limiter son
influence sur le raisonnement il en va
de même avec la société il faut
reconnaître qu'elle suit un système de
valeurs et qu'elle distingue entre davis
et des vertus
comme on le disait avec les ristote mais
aussi elle explosa dans plein d'autres
vidéos ses valeurs naissent d'un désir
car qui dit désir d'y finalité
les systèmes de valeurs découle
directement de ce qui est visé ce qui
est logique du reste puisque
naturellement on vise ceux que l'on
considère comme bon
comme on dit au début de la vidéo pour
les croyances il y a les systèmes de
valeurs de surface et les systèmes de
valeurs profond les premiers envois aux
valeurs qu'on défend consciemment dont
on peut répondre si on nous interroge
dessus les second renvoie valeurs qui
sont ancrés en nous et qui oriente notre
comportement il arrive que les deux
systèmes coïncide il arrive que ce ne
soit pas le cas il arrive surtout que
l'on pense ne pas avoir de système de
valeurs du tout simplement parce qu'on
n'a pas de système de valeurs de surface
et parce qu'on ignore la présence d'un
système de valeurs profond mais tout le
monde
un système de valeurs qu'on le veuille
ou non si vous avez des désirs vous
adhérez un système de valeurs et comme
la société batipart des humains elle
nourrit certaines valeurs plutôt que
d'autres aussi on peut dire que la
société n'est pas impartial dans sa
manière de traiter des individus parce
qu'elle préfère certaines formes de vie
à d'autres ses préférences dépendent de
ses désirs dont de l'objectif qu'elle se
donne
il est donc super important de discuter
de l'objectif en question il est
impératif de se demander quel genre de
monde
notre société cherche-t-elle à produire
sans surprise les individus qui
composent une société sont influencés
par le système de valeurs dans laquelle
il laisse évolue par défaut et sans
forcément se rendre compte
nous désirons un monde nous nourrissons
une conception de ce qui est bon ou
mauvais pour la société et ses désirs se
construisent en relation au désir qui
nous entoure au système de valeurs
dominant il faut interroger ses
influences ça tombe bien le super site
cette éthique metacritic fait une série
à ce sujet pour aider à prendre
conscience de la présence de biais
idéologique
si nous ne rendons pas explicite ce que
nous souhaitons que monde nous ne
pouvons pas débattre des moyens pour y
parvenir
cette question peut paraître effrayantes
notamment parce qu'elle met en péril
l'idéal rassurant du consensus cherché à
répondre c'est probablement dû courir
que nous ne voulons pas tous le même
monde et que nous ne voyons pas le même
monde
c'est comprendre qu'il va falloir faire
certains compromis on ne pourra pas se
reposer sur la vérité vraie pour
trancher une fois pour toutes il va
falloir faire le travail tous ensemble
pour bâtir une société plus juste et ça
va pas être simple
il y aura du conflit mais je crois que
ça vaut le coup alors voilà la question
que je vous pose et j'attends vos
réponses en commentaires ou sur twitter
qu'elle monte voulez vous ah oui au fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du libre arbitre
quelle est votre position là dessus je
veux faire un format court bientôt mais
je vous donne un indice
je crois qu'il ya des moments où il faut
y croire et des moments où il est
préférable de garder à l'esprit que
c'est une illusion il non ce n'est pas
une réponse de normand c'est fini
grand merci à mes électeurs et vos
lectrices si vous avez envie de soutenir
la chaîne
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à partager
etc etc tous les soutiens aide à
continuer et donc du coup merci à vous
qui nous soutiennent depuis le début
salut à bientôt
elle